[Music]
one important theme in ursula kayla
green's novel a wizard of earth see that
might be easily
overlooked as something just
ancillary a kind of extra helping along
the plot
is the friendship between two of the
characters one of them the main
character sparrowhawk or
ged and the other one the slightly older
person that he meets
at the isle of roke and becomes deep
friends with vetch or estario
as his his true name and you might
easily overlook this because
it's not something that is thematized
throughout the entire work as a matter
of fact
a lot of what get is doing is moving
from place to place to place
staying only so long as he has to
starting out at gaunt where he's a child
and then studies under odeon then he's
sent to roque there's the terrible
catastrophe there he gets sent out to
the 90 aisles where he confronts the
dragon he goes north to oskill back to
roque again and then starts traveling
around trying to hunt down
his shadow and only when we get to
the isle of isme does
does vetch his great friend come back
into the story again but if we look at
this relationship it's probably
i mean i don't want to say that it's the
only super deep uh
friendship or relationship there's also
ogen his
former uh master in in rogue but this is
something where the two of them are you
might say on the same level whereas with
ogen at first he's above and then he
says you're going to be much greater
than i am
and there's there's a vast age
difference so what what's happening with
vetch i do want to start out by talking
about
one thing that leguin brings up and this
is once they're actually
back together
on the isle of ismay
they've met up again
and
she tells us this is long before they
they actually
leave that
here we go the love between them was
strong and steadfast unshaken
by time or chance and that's really
quite something because if you think
about friendships what what make
friendships the friendships that we
enjoy
there's a vast variety of friendships as
philosophers
have you know made clear from ancient
times think about aristotle and his
discussion of three main kinds of
friendships and then others as well in
nick mccain ethics books eight and nine
or cicero's entire work
on friendship love affection
you know a kind of attachment to each
other a
well-wishing a care for each other that
is part of friendship we delight
in being with the friend and
strong and steadfast a constancy to it
and unshaken
by the distance in time many years have
actually passed
or
chance where we happen to be
if we're really friends with somebody
then we can take up that friendship even
though things have changed even though
we have aged even though
we may have different preoccupations and
new attachments to others
we can take that friendship back up
we've we've got place for that person
in our hearts now how does this come to
pass well we need to go to rogue in
order to see how this is developing the
first person his own age that the young
sparrowhawk meets at rogue is this jerk
jasper who he's a rival with but shortly
after that he meets vetch
this is at the long table of the ref
refractory where he's sitting down to
eat the noon
meal and
we see that here we go jasper took ged
to sit with a heavyset fellow named
vetch who said nothing much but shoveled
in his food with a will he had the
accent of the east reach and was very
dark of skin not red brown like like get
in jasper and most folk of the
archipelago but black brown he was plain
and his manners were not polished he
grumbled about the dinner when he had
finished it but then turning to ged it
said at least it's not illusion like so
much around here it sticks to your ribs
ged did not know what he meant but he
felt a certain liking for him and was
glad when after the meal he stayed
with them and so there's some
commonalities there you know get is from
gant and not one of the big cultured
centers like jasper is and so maybe he
feels a little bit more at ease
with
that veggies also speaking his mind not
talking and riddles or anything like
that
a little bit later there's you know
some playing around
vetch tells him that's the imminent
grove we can't come there yet he and
jasper and vetch uh ghent are going
around and uh jasper is is you know
saying let's do some magic tricks
get isn't ready for it vetch says let
him be a while and you know we have this
this constant um
you could say theme of jasper pushing
ged responding out of rivalry and envy
and vets saying listen guys let's be
reasonable
a little bit later in that same chapter
uh
we see that that
gad is wrapped in his cloak on the
mattress and his cold unlit cell of
stone
darkness surrounded him dreadfilled him
he wished he was anywhere but rogue but
vetch came to the door
a little bluish ball of where light
nodding over his head to light the way
and asked if he could come in and talk
he asked gad about god then spoke fondly
of his own home isles of the east reach
telling how the smoke of village
hearthfires is blown across that quiet
seat evening between the small islands
with funny names
corp cop and hope venue vemish ifish
coppischen snag
when he sketched the shapes of those
lands on the stones of the floor with
his finger to show get how they lay the
lines he drew shone dim as if drawn with
a stick of silver for a while before
they faded vetch had been three years at
the school and soon would be made
sorcerer he thought no more of
performing the lesser arts of magic than
a bird thinks of flying yet a greater
unlearned skill he possessed which was
the art
of kindness
so we're getting to see
vetch's character here
he's a genuine person he looks after
somebody who he can he can tell is on
his own and feeling
lonely and feeling
out of place
um welcoming extending friendship to
together this is very important it also
puzzles get a bit that um
vetch
likes
jasper and and is willing to hang out
with him he's he's not quite
uh sure about
why that's happening but there's you
know uh
it's not taking away from what
uh vetch is providing good
we see that that um
god makes another friend a little furry
friend
the otak the creatures found only on the
four southern isles of the archipelago
small and sleek with broad faces dark
fur brown or brindle and great bright
eyes their teeth are cruel they're
temper fierce so they're not made pets
of
god stroked this one and it woke and
yawned showing a small brown tongue and
white teeth but it was not afraid otak
he said then remembering the thousands
of beasts he the names of bc had learned
in the tower he called it by its true
name in the old speech
do you want to come with me and the otak
hangs out with him and vetch says wow
that's that's really cool you know
they say sparrow hawk a man favored by a
wild beast is a man to whom the old
powers of stone and spring will speak in
human voice so
that's going on now
it's also important to note that in the
wizards duel which as vetch points out
they're not supposed to be doing right
between jasper and ged
when
ged opens up this rift between this
world and another between the light and
the darkness
who is it that rushes to his aid jasper
hides his face the other apprentices run
away of course the ark mage is going to
be coming and uh you know closing up the
rift but what we see
is vetch vechalone ran forward to his
friend
only he saw the lump of shadow that
clung to ged tearing at his flesh vetch
sobbed with horror yet he put out his
hands to try to pull the thing away from
ged before he touched it he was bound
still unable to move right and so thatch
is the only one of all of those fellow
sorcerers and training who
reaches out who tries to do anything and
afterwards he comes to
to get he's been taking care of the otak
sparrowhawk at the sound of the voice
god raised his eyes it was vetch
standing there solid and four squares as
ever his black burnt fa blunt face older
but his smile unchanged on his shoulder
crouched a little beast brindle furred
and bright-eyed
he stayed with me while you were sick
and now i'm sorry to part with him and
sorry or to part with you sparrowhawk
but i'm going home
here hoyg go to your true master vetch
padded the otak and set it down on the
floor it went and sat on god's palate
and begin to wash its fur ged says
i thought you wouldn't come to me vetch
vetch says i couldn't come to you the
master herbal forbade me and since
winter i've been with the master in the
grove i wasn't free until i earned my
staff listen when you are free come to
the east reach i will be waiting for you
there's good cheer in the little towns
and wizards are well received and they
they talk a bit more
and vetch says i don't see you staying
here in rooms and books but far seas and
the fire of dragons and the towers of
cities
vetch says
where are you going to go what are you
going to do
and vetch says i will go home to see my
brothers and the sister you've heard me
speak of i left her a little child soon
she'll be having her name and it's
strange to think of i'll find me a job
of wizardry somewhere along among the
little isles oh i would stay and talk
with you but i can't my ship goes out
tonight and the tide is turned already
and then something happens something is
done
that is
very important
vetch gives gad his true name
he says
if you ever need for me send for me
call on me by my name
estario
at that gad lift his lifted his scarred
face meeting his friend's eyes estario
my name is ged
then quietly they bait each other
farewell
vetch turned and went down the stone
hallway and left rogue dead stood still
a while like one who's received great
news and must enlarge his spirit to
receive it it was a great gift vetch had
given him the knowledge of his true name
no one knows a man's true name but
himself and his neighbor he may choose
at length to tell it to his brother or
his wife or his friend yet even those
few will never use it where any third
person
may
hear it in front of other people they
will like other people call him by his
use name his nickname such a name as
sparrowhawk and vetch and ogion which
means fire cone
who knows a man's name
holds that man's life in his keeping
thus to ged who had lost faith in
himself
vetch had given that gift only a friend
can give
the proof of
unshaken
unshakable trust
this is something that restores
confidence
life even to to get who has been
wavering after this
terrible thing that has happened and
estario or vetch is going to help get
out in dealing with that at the end at
ismay
he welcomes get into his house and his
family we see
that he encounters
[Applause]
ged
as gad is chasing the shadow
he says
here we go
he he heard a man and a girl talking
merrily as they came down the street
passed him towards the town square all
at once he turned free knew the man's
voice
he followed and caught up with the pair
coming up beside them in the late
twilight the girl stepped back but the
man stared at him then flung up the
staff he carried holding it between them
as a
barrier to ward off the threat or act of
evil and that was something somewhat
more than ged could bear his voice shook
a little as he said i thought you would
know me vetch
even then vetch hesitated for a moment i
do know you then lowered the staff and
took ged's hand and hugged him around
the shoulders i do know you welcome my
friend welcome what a sorry greeting i
gave you and then he says what's going
on what's up with that well i also saw
you three days ago well that was my
shadow and we'll talk about that
elsewhere
so
he tells he tells god in the true speech
in trouble and from darkness you come
get yet your coming is joy to me
and he introduces him to his sister
takes him into his house
and uh like he says though he was the
chief wizard in the whole island of
ifitch he made his home in isme this
small town where he had been born living
with his youngest brother and sister
and they stay up all night talking
together there's a lot of back and forth
talking about the situation that gad is
in
and uh
vetch is going to give him good counsel
and you know some back and forth
dialogue about it but he's also going to
tell tell him that he shouldn't be
prideful that uh here we go
ged told him what's going on vetch said
sat pondering for a long while and then
said i'll go with you get
no
i think i will
no estario this is no task or bane of
yours i began this evil course alone i
will finish it alone i do not want any
other to suffer from it
you least of all who tried to keep my
hand from the evil act in the very
beginning and so get is actually making
a very good argument here saying listen
buddy you were the only person who
actually tried to keep me from doing
this stupid thing
and then you you know you stood there
tried to save me you've done way more
than you need to do
and estario or vetch says to him
pride was ever your mind's master now
think it is your quest assuredly but if
the quest fails
should there not be another who might
bear warning to the archipelago for the
shadow would be a fearful power then if
you defeat the thing should there not be
another who will tell of it in the
archipelago that the deed may be known
and sung i know i can be of no use to
you
yet i think i should go with you
so to ged's good argument
estario or vetch makes a great counter
argument you know
if this thing takes control of you
somebody's got to be there to like do
you in or at least
uh sink the sink the boat or
take the news back to the archipelago
that evil is on its way and if you do
survive somebody has to tell everybody
about this
so that's that's very important as well
he commits to helping god
then the final chapter the open sea is
the two of them
sailing
at you know isle after isle in the
reaches
going past last land to confront god's
shadow they sail even further
and what they find is
you know either an illusion or a reality
of dry land that they wind up in ged
confronts the shadow
uh beats it if you can say so
uh
rather reincorporates what was taken
into himself and then um
there's a moment of worry
god says estario look it's done it's
over he laughed the wound is healed i am
whole i'm free then he bent over and hit
his face in his arms
weeping like a boy
until that moment vetch had watched him
with an anxious dread for he was not
sure what had happened there in the dark
land he did not know if this was get in
the boat with him and his hand had been
for hours ready to the anchor to stave
in the boat's planking and sink her
there in mid sea
rather than carry back to the harbors of
mercy the evil thing that he feared
might have taken god's look and form
now when he saw his friend and heard him
speak his doubt vanished
and so
what we find then the song that vetch
saying aloud now as he held the boat
westward going before the cold wind of
the winter night that blew at their
backs from the vastness of the open sea
is only in silence the word only in dark
the light only in dying life bright the
hawks flight on the empty sky they
sailed back
and the book ends by talking about
estario or vatch
if astario avific kept his promise and
made a song
of that great first deed of gods it has
been lost
there's a tale told in the east reach of
a boat that ran aground days out from
any shore over the abyss of ocean in
ifish they say it was a starial who
sailed that boat but in talk they say it
was two fishermen blown by a storm far
out on the open sea and then hope the
odd the tail is of a hopeless fisherman
and tells he could not move his boat so
the sawing of the shadow there remains
only a few scraps of legend
carried like driftwood from isle to isle
over the long years but in the deed of
ged
nothing is told to that voyage nor of
ged's meeting with the shadow and you
know that is where it it ends and so
it's fitting that we have things kind of
left hanging but we have this wonderful
friendship
so instrumental to ged being able to
ultimately confront his shadow aided by
his friend vech
or estario
you